I even read that you had very dark
thoughts even suicide coming you know
it's funny my therapist is amazing and
she had asked me feel suicidal thought I
said hell I don't have suicidal thoughts
I'm not crazy and the shields lies
across your mind I go oh yeah she goes
those are suicidal thoughts even if it's
not like I'm cutting myself or jump
shoot it for you to even think that for
you to even have that thought cross your
mind for you to even think that you're
not going to see your parents or you
know your god trailer and I'm like wow I
really didn't think about that I mean
that Monday was probably the worst day
of my entire life like it words can't
describe like how I felt I just was in a
dark room I had a sheet over my like
window I had probably like 50
publications and outlets you know
outside of my place doorbells ring and
phone was going off I know what to do i
I just kind of sit there and just cried
oh you know I do because I didn't know
what to do and I didn't know how to
overcome and how okay so you're in that
place how did you overcome well you know
my mother my father and a cast mate my
cast mates Eric reached out to me and
was like man you need a PR you need and
I'm like I don't even know even if I was
to find a PR if you know he or she I
mean are they good or are they in it for
me how do I know that it's not somebody
who's out there I you know I mean all
these thoughts start crossing your minds
I mean I know a really good PR he sent
me uh you know a Bible verse you know
like the trials and tribulations and
it's so crazy how the Bible like and I'm
like reading the Bible that Monday and
it's something I've never read in my
entire life
and just to kind of I'm reading them
like this is what I'm experiencing right
now and it just you know what helped you
know calm me down and speak and my
mother and my father and you know but
where were you waiting to hear down you
know but did they send you home right
alone no so they sent me home uh you
know they sent me home or my cup because
like a Thursday or so I didn't know
anything was I thought it was just I
just got eliminate it I was fine okay
cool that's all right and then all of a
sudden Sunday came and I got home from
the gym and a buddy had caught me it was
like yo
man like what happened in paradise I'm
like what do you mean and he's like
didn't go online and I've ever going
online and I remember just seeing a
picture it's like get Korean consent did
Demario rape her and I'm like whoa whoa
whoa like what's going on and I kind of
sat there and I'm I'm pacing back and
forth and I go see my dad he's like
what's wrong and I'm like no it's all so
crazy stuff like internet about me like
but it's not true no it's okay you know
it's okay like you know you got this you
got this calm down breathe you know and
I really don't think too much of it okay
it was just like a few gossip sites so I
didn't think anything of it and I woke
up that Monday and it was like World War
three and I remember looking outside of
my place it was all these like like
we're looking cars and vans and I went
outside to check the mail and it was
like I mean I feel like Princess Diana
it was like I'm sitting there I didn't
know this I mean it wasn't like I did a
Transformers movie and it came out on
Sunday and I knew that Monday my life
was about to change this was something
like I went to sleep on Sunday as a
regular guy and I woke up on the front
page of all these publications and
newspapers and my mom was getting
harassed my dad's getting harassed my
kid sisters can harass my grandmother's
getting her ass I'm like wow
none of us signed up for this but you
seem so I mean even though if you were
in a dark place you have you have a such
a positive spirit right now I was built
for this my parents taught me at a very
very young age that the world is not
perfect that you will be under scrutiny
you will be called names you'll be when
you're african-american things are
different like for us and I don't live
my life like I'm not one of those angry
guys like all it's different but it's
different for us like when I get over by
the cop at mines my whole family is in
law enforcement I get pulled over by a
cop I know it's a few things that I have
to do I have my white friends I've been
pulled over with them and they're
officer this is Matt like they're going
off and I'm sitting here like wow I
can't do that if I go to a restaurant I
have service I can't not tip because
it's a it's a you know thing that goes
around a black people don't tip so it's
already gonna be like oh they don't tip
anyway like I have to tip 30 40 percent
to over cut so it's a certain amount of
things and I remembered all this
scrutiny all this hate and all this
racism and all this kind of stuff and
I'm
pop just kept me it's okay remember when
you were getting recruited I remember
when that coach told you you weren't
good enough what you do and like he
would break everything down for me
and I just kind of sat there and I had
to talk to my mom and my dad and they're
like look you know we're going to get
through this because you know what's on
the tape and producers have already told
you what's on the tape and you just have
to kind of sit in this burning room and
just wait for everything to come out and
that was the hardest thing for me